they know how to build the lead they
just don't know how to hold the lead and
i was feeling pretty good because one of
your best bets of the week was the bears
getting three one of my picks was the
falcons to win
straight out it's 26 to 10. and
i'm getting ready to light the victory
cigar and everything's looking good
and then matt oh baby bears has an idea
he has a thought he has a gut
feeling that it's time to remove
mitchell trubisky who brought the team
back
from a 17-point deficit week one at
detroit
down 16 in the second half to the
falcons
it was time for the super bowl 52 mvp
nick foles
to make his entrance and with that very
questionable call
via replay review that had a touchdown
turn into an interception
or as referee jerome boger said to troll
all bears fans the ruling is a touch
back it was just like oh why are you
doing this to bears fans
at that point i'm thinking it's done
it's over see you later 26 to 10
falcons can't blow this lead well they
did blow it and
nick foles led the comeback and it's
created a quarterback conundrum for the
chicago bears his
here's nick foles after the game talking
about getting an unexpected opportunity
and pulling it off for the bears
i think uh just from experience playing
this game
obviously you know practice throughout
the week you don't get reps so
you're constantly getting mental reps
and being prepared and running the scout
team just trying to play ball and
it really came down to you know we were
down by a little bit and our defense did
a great job of holding them
and just going out there playing ball
trusting guys watching the defense
watching the secondary getting us to
good plays if we need b
and executing um you know the way i
approach the game is one play at a time
so
it's not easy coming in cold like that
but if you can
approach it with the mindset hey just
one play at a time you can't get all the
points back in one throw
that helps a lot
you know when matt nagy made mitchell
trubisky the starting quarterback before
week one i said at some point this year
nick foles will play either due to
injury or ineffectiveness of trubisky
i just never would have dreamed it would
happen in the third game after a
two-and-oh start when trubisky did bring
them back
right from a 17-point deficit i just
wonder how much of his performance week
two when they had the 17-point lead that
they tried to blow
plus on top of it right the struggles on
third down and in the red zone that's
what neggie told me after the game it
was a gut feeling
that arose from their struggles on third
down and in the red zone there was an
interception on third down that trubisky
through that just created the feeling
where he decided i need to do this and
the fact that it worked
right they went back last night to alice
hall the offensive coaching staff
huddling to decide who the who the
quarterback will be
for next week and yeah right yeah right
what was the huddle let me here was the
huddle hey guys
nick foles the quarterback see you
tomorrow nick foles on one here's the
huddle
nick falls on one right break yes
exactly i mean what there can't be a
conversation at this point
i mean i'm with you mike i was shocked
that they were
you know pulling the switch yesterday on
mitchell trubisky
it wasn't pretty i understand that
there's no doubt but
i'm sitting there going okay well maybe
you know maybe here we go maybe he can
create some of the magic
that he had in week one like you
mentioned but i mean first off the fact
that nick foles is wearing a dark visor
and number nine looking like jim mcmahon
coming in the game
i don't know maybe he was made to be the
quarterback but
second of all i think mike with what
you're saying i think there must be more
there to what they haven't liked with
mitchell trubisky
listen week one wasn't good the game
laid out for him to where he can make a
few plays late and they came back i
didn't sit there and go like oh my gosh
he dissected the lions wow on my unreal
you know no they just two or three plays
one swung the game
he made them and that was great it
didn't have the look of what nick foles
showed us yesterday
nick foles was what i just said
dissection
you as soon as you got in the game you
went man he just looks better in the
pocket
the ball seems to be in the right areas
all the time
it comes out of his hand clean every
time spirals
and the one thing that always jumps out
to me mike and we saw it yesterday is
his ability to throw with people around
him you know the game-winning touchdown
all-out blitz got somebody hitting him
throws a post right
right on the money you know those are
things that we just don't see trubisky
do consistently and
i understand the switch even though i
was surprised just like you
three quick points on that first of all
the hit that he took on the last
touchdown pass the kind of thing that
will get teammates behind
the huddle of nick foles on one ready
break number two
that's how he broke his collarbone last
year so you don't know how many of those
hits he's going to be able to take so
you may need trubisky again at some
point
and then finally we don't know how
foles has responded over the last few
weeks in
practice after trubisky got the starting
job because
trubisky earned it based on practice
performances without the benefit of
any preseason games and maybe true
biscuit well obviously trubisky
practiced a hell of a lot better than
falls because remember
when they gave the job to trubisky there
was no
pushback from anyone that they made the
wrong choice no there was no
rumbling no unnamed sources no schism in
the locker room
between trubisky and falls and the
decision to flip
the switch at some level
may have been influenced by things we
don't know about like
foals has looked pretty damn good in
practice and
maybe there's starting to be some
grumbling from
the older veteran leadership on the team
and that all goes into the blender that
results in the gut feeling what starts
as a gut feeling
and ends up being a permanent switch and
i think
maybe out of respect to mitchell
trubisky
they went through the motions last night
maybe that's what it is they haven't
made the decision yet right we don't
know about it yet
i'm gonna be surprised if it's anything
but nick falls because
naggy told me i don't want to go back
and forth well
if that's the case you don't want the
guy you just went back and forth on no
you don't want the guy you just removed
you want the guy that you're going to
feel good about it validate your
decision
yes to go with foals he came back and
won it i'll be
stunned if that's not the pick and
chris we're 10 days away from nick foles
versus tom brady
if foles is the guy which is another
great benefit
of that gut feeling if that's the way it
goes yeah it is it's amazing and mike i
think you know
your point first off about trubisky
maybe doing things that we don't know
or whatever it is hey third down first
off when when
when matt nagy says things to you like a
third downs bad
and all the red zone those are
quarterback areas
i mean third down is the quarterback
down in football you look at the legends
of the sport the really good
quarterbacks the one thing you can
always look at is go
they're good on third down because
they're smart they're big time throwers
they know they got to be a little
aggressive to get the first down so we
got to push the envelope that way
so we don't know and also we don't know
is trubisky messing up
checks and doing things like that that
we might not even be able to tell
you know watching film or watching on tv
so
you know there is that aspect and then
of course that last interception
trubisky threw the pick
six or not the pick six but the pick
that ended up
only being a field goal because the the
bears defense
balled out really at the later part of
that game um
that was just uh you know unexcusable
it's it was
a zone coverage he threw a shallow
crosser like it was man-to-man like
nobody was there the guy was just
standing there and i think with that
that was probably so alarming to niggy
to go whoa he's really not seeing the
field well
if he threw that ball like that and then
there is there's just a difference in
falls there's no way they can go
back at this point and mike sorry last
thing i just want to hit on because i
know
when trubisky was named the starter i
thought
wow he must have really like dominated
in training camp to what you were saying
because you bring in nick foles you
think man if it's close you're ready to
you're ready to pull the trigger and
just go hey nick foles we brought him
here let's go
but this brings me back to like i think
it must have been close
and trubisky just won out and they
almost like gave him the respect to go
okay you've been the starter and you've
done some good things here here go ahead
be the starter and they won two games
even though they were kind of ugly
i think they just had enough and this is
their their best chance there's no doubt
from what i saw yesterday full should be
the guy
yeah and as tony dungy said last night
something he learned from dennis green
in 1992 when green
benched rich gannon for sean salisbury
once you remove your starter and put the
next guy in the next guy is your starter
yeah
period right and you can't go back to
trubisky
the fans in chicago have been waiting
for this for a couple of years
and now they ride with foals and see how
far falls can take them
and he's entering the job with two wins
already in the bank and a third one that
he earned it's going to be a little
harder though
degree of difficulty is increased
running back tariq cohen neggie told me
after the game
it's fear that he has a torn acl you
know they can tell by manipulation they
need to do the mri to confirm it
but without tariq khan and he said they
were just getting to the point where
cohen really understood the offense and
they really knew how to use him
because remember it was kind of it was
kind of not you know not not
not overwhelming no but but he was
coming into his own and uh
and now they're going to have to try to
replace that production with someone
else which is going to put more pressure
on the quarterback
yeah it is there's no you know there's
still a work in progress that's that's
the big thing
but i would imagine that with nick foles
back in the fold here
you're gonna see numbers like you saw
with allen robinson yesterday
again because that's where i mean foles
is
big receiver like alan robinson pretty
aggressive thrower down the field that's
alan robinson's game 50 50 balls
curls break a tackle run down the
sideline for a touchdown
uh i would think you're gonna see the
receiver play for the bears
you know the statistics themselves
really pick up
and this bears teams interesting because
their defense yesterday too
let's not forget they had moments of
really whooping the crap out of atlanta
atlanta got very fortunate
i mean they called the penalty on the
bears one time for a strip sack fumble
they got the ball in field goal
territory
but like they just they hit matt ryan so
hard i think the referee was like that's
got to be illegal
i don't know and it wasn't it was just
hard football but i mean
they really got screwed over two
different times they're a team to keep
our eye on though because if foals can
kind of get hot this offense get going
their defense is top notch and a couple
of games against the packers coming up
and both teams are three and oh
and leaving the lions and the vikings in
the dust the vikings as well
bye-bye vikings
i don't care i don't care it's
scholarship here they're on scholarship
you got to fully enjoy your scholarship
year
they'll focus next year on actually
trying to win football games the falcons
will as well we'll talk more about
where they may go from here you know i
got a couple of teams that i think are
already on
coach dead man walking watch the falcons
and it's the jets
and we'll have plenty of time this week
to talk about the jets because they play
the broncos
on thursday night a couple of winless
teams getting together
but uh between the falcons and the jets
right now it's not looking good and at
least
the falcons are getting leads
they just continue this narrative of not
being able to hold leads
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports